june 5th
leonard ross of saiyan a thief hanged at
statsdenak
was my first execution wolf faber of
gutzendorf and bartle dochent
of vastefels both executed at stat
chronic
wolf who was a thief was hanged bartel
who was a murderer and had committed
three murders
was executed on the wheel bartel muscle
of mechan rule
a murderer who single-handedly committed
two murders the first at bamberg at the
millware where he stabbed a man and took
his money
the other at velkendorf on the mountains
when he cut the throat of a man who was
sleeping with him on the straw in his
shed
and took his money beheaded at holfeld
and exposed
on the wheel this was my first execution
with the sword
march 19th a burler eckhart a young
person of nuremberg
a thief as a favor beheaded standing
with the sword
here in nuremberg july 13th a woman who
murdered her illegitimate child
executed by drowning august 6th
hans buchner who had previously been
whipped out of the town at nuremberg
george gabler of schoenfeld michael
dietrich of pernitsvin
whose alias was the margrave three
thieves and robbers
beheaded here with the sword and exposed
on the wheel
when they were being led out the
margrave's wife wanted to see the poor
sinners as they passed
and saw her own husband among them whom
she embraced and kissed
for she had not known her husband had
been arrested nor that he was a fellow
of that sort
a thief who was also a cup purse hanged
a thief hanged
a murderer beheaded two thieves hanged
january 10th christoph houck whose alias
was the fiddling
cobbler from neuenstadt a shoemaker by
trade
also a fiddler and drummer and a great
thief he also played the jester at the
tower festivals
hanged at nuremberg took leave from the
world as a christian
he'd been spared the gallows 12 years
before at comback
george presagul of notska a thief who
killed his wife and afterwards hanged
her so it might be supposed she had
hanged and destroyed herself
had also formally stabbed a man beheaded
with the sword at nuremberg
and dissected that is to say cut up
george sharp for lecher guilty of
beastliness with four cows
two calves and a sheep beheaded for
unnatural
vice advel and afterwards burnt together
with a cow
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
as you guys know magellan have been
great supporters of content from me and
my brother for a while now
and it's through their support that i
can produce longer form documentaries
here on voices of the past
and next month something truly special
is coming
ancient china and the west magellan are
basically a netflix for documentaries
with over 3000 quality works in their
library
a great example that goes well with this
video in particular is crimes that made
history
a great series that touches on some of
the wildest stories of illegality
from the past and you can now take
advantage of an exclusive offer
30 off an annual membership this gives
you an
entire year for less than 3.50 a month
even if you've joined magellan before
and lapsed
you can simply click on the link in the
description to claim your discounted
membership today
thanks
february the 20th catherine brooklyn a
native of birkenstart
formerly called stamlet kathra and the
foreigner
whom my father formerly whipped out of
the town of preserve with rods
lately consulting with thieves and
robbers formed a band of sixteen
and attacked people by night at many
places
bound their victims tortured beat and
wounded them
forced and extorted money from them
robbed and stole their clothes
beheaded with the sword at nuremberg she
should have been executed on the same
day 12 weeks earlier
but obtained a respite on the pretext of
pregnancy
which was not true anna bischoffen of
augsburg
formerly whipped out of wurzburg and
branded on the cheeks
set fire to a shed at kudzun farm at
lauff on st john's baptist day on
account of a purse
which she had mislaid and thought had
been stolen from her beheaded with the
sword
standing at lauff her body burnt her
head set up on the scaffold
gave out she was pregnant thinking to
obtain a respite
but it was not true henser of geiselwind
whose alias was the fat lad henser
paulaf of hernda
kilian verm of vernsbach hans schwerber
and hensler klopfer five thieves who
with the previously executed silly mary
and country kate
had burgled and stolen they'd also
formally been whipped out and put in the
stocks
ten times they had to be clothed for
they were naked and bare
some of them knew no prayers and had
never been in a church
the oldest were 22 17 16 and 15 years
old
the youngest 13 years all five
hanged here in nuremberg
[Music]
march 24th heinrich hurt whose alias was
the shopman
a thief and murderer killed a carrier
who had driven to the town for 30 years
and took his money took 17 florins from
another carter
six florins from another carter and also
stole
four horses executed on the wheel at
nuremberg
anna palestine of nuremberg because she
had had carnal intercourse
with a father and a son and similarly
with 21 married men and youths
her husband conniving was beheaded here
with the sword
standing her husband called jerome
pilestein
was whipped out of the town he wrote
these lines on the wall of saint peter's
church near her grave
father and son should have been treated
as she was in the other world
i shall summon emperor and king because
justice has not been done
i poor man suffer though innocent
farewell and good night
february 9th elizabeth auerhaltin who
tried to defraud people
giving out that she could conjure and
dig up treasure as she did with devilish
incantations and ceremonies
at the houses of a soldier's wife of
councillor fisher's wife etc
this was how she carried out her tricks
when she came into a house and wanted to
cheat someone
she used to fall down as if she was ill
or in convulsions
giving out afterwards that she had a
wise vein hidden in her leg
whereby she could foretell and reveal
future events
and discover hidden treasures and that
when she entered a house
her veins never left her in peace until
she announced these things
also that the realms of earth were
opened out before her and that she saw
therein
gold and silver as if looking into a
fire
if any doubted she asked them to spend
the night in the house
so that she could speak with the spirit
of the treasure
when this happened she behaved at night
with her whisperings questions and
answers
as if someone was speaking to her and
gave out afterwards that it was a poor
lost
soul who could not enter into bliss and
that they must dig
for treasure then the people let
themselves be persuaded by her
believing such tales because of the
horrible incantations which she used and
caused the ground
to be dug up during this digging she
would slip a pot full of coals into the
hole
and give out that she had dug it up
herself this she commanded them to lock
up in a chest for three weeks and not
touch it
and then it would turn to gold meanwhile
she decamped and the coals remained
coles
she was beheaded here on account of her
frauds
had only one leg and had to be carried
to execution
may 7th matthew sturtz of gruntling
a soldier who had served in five
campaigns stabbed a ditcher of eilsdorf
near the rabenstein because he is said
to have begged of him and when the
burger master spoke to him
asking why he had so wounded him he
stabbed him also
went afterwards into the city and asked
to be tried had been a catholic
but turned lutheran beheaded adelsdorf
may 27th kuntzner who 12 years ago on
account of some pigeons taken from him
and also being drunk in his fury set
fire to and burnt down his house and
helped to extinguish the fire with
others
then three years ago he stole to the
value of 60 florins from one of his
friends at purngau
and when the latter thrashed him for it
he threatened to burn his house
so that the friend had to agree to pay
50 florence besides
then also threatened one of his friends
at the rock stalk from whom he had
stolen a cow and who had recovered it
that if he did not give him 15 florence
he would burn down his house and farm
so that it could be swept up with a
broom afterwards lastly he stole much in
the way of bedclothes and corn at
different times
for these crimes he was beheaded as a
favor at salzburg
october 13th conrad svicklesburger
burger and compass maker of this town
because of his immoral relations with
barbara wagner and
a carpenter's wife which however began
before he had a wife and sheer husband
three times he prompted the woman to put
insect powder in her husband's food
this she did putting it in some porridge
and even eating three spoonfuls herself
which powder did not harm the man he
vomited six times and she twice
for as zvikel had told her if she gave
him too much he would die
if little he would only vomit zvikel
also pledged himself by going to
communion
not have intimacy with any other woman
than with her the carpenter's wife
and she was to go and promise him the
same also the man's vehicle gave to
florence to an old witch that she might
cause the carpenter to be stabbed
struck down or drowned in the same way
he had had immoral relations with the
mother of the carpenter's wife 24 years
before
and also with three sisters called
fisterin
as well as with other married women for
these crimes he was beheaded as a favor
and his body burnt
march 20th benedict n who lived by
stealing and other evil doings
was the son of a citizen and took to a
vagrant life in various parts
lived about here in saint john's quarter
and made a living at the gambling houses
beheaded with the sword as a favor june
26th
a book binder who stole more than 300
florins worth of goods from his master
besides he entered houses by night at
various times and stole
tin copper clothes cloaks meat which he
disposed of afterwards
the ladder was already placed against
the gallows for him but he was beheaded
as a favor
by the timber stacks september the 11th
two citizens here one a wire drawer
called kepler
quite ruined the iron merchant bartel
costart by his thefts
for he entered his warehouse by night
and locked it after him again so that no
one saw or watched him
he stole iron wire and steel nails in
considerable quantities
causing the goods to be hawked and sold
among the work people by his wife and
children
he also dealt in false coin the other a
gardener and regular carrier and
messenger
called the cabbage grower who was
entrusted with money several times and
often found untrustworthy
lately ventured on a good trick
knowing that he was carrying to
frankfurt some silver jewelry and money
which he had received here from worthy
master rosenthaler
and for which he was responsible he
opened the parcel
sold some of the contents wasted the
money in eating and
gambling then made himself scarce but at
last
news was received that he was living in
foreign territory
both men hanged burnt alive here and
miller of man burner
who however was lately engaged as a
carrier of wine
because he and his brother with the help
of others practiced
coining and counterfeiting money and
clipping coins fraudulently
he also had a knowledge of magic
this miller who had worked in the town
mills here three years ago
fell into the town moat on whitson day
it would have been better for him if he
had drowned
but it turned out according to the
proverb what belongs
to the gallows cannot drown in water
[Music]
this was the last person whom i
master friends executed